free code camp i put that right at the
beginning because i'm like this is
always gonna be free i want people to
know it's free
you know free code camp like it's the
community for uh
busy adults essentially most of them are
working full time a lot of them have
kids mortgages
what we do is we break everything up
into
extremely bite-sized little chunks where
you can hop on and productively code
information is infinitely reproducible
there's no reason that we have to charge
money for information i feel like if you
if you're blessed
with abundance you have a duty should
you choose to hear keep the call
to go out and try to help other people
welcome to coffeezilla another edition
of the sunday special today
we have a very exciting episode got the
lambo in the back
because we're talking about knowledge
okay today we have quincy larson the
founder of
free code camp and i'm here to talk to
you guys it's a positive episode
quincy thanks for coming hey thanks for
having me man
quincy first tell me about your
background your site free code camp
is a place where anyone can get a
programming education
for free right yep that's right no
strings attached no uh
no backdoor agreements actually for free
yeah you just have to put in the time
which is a big ask for a lot of people
but yeah that's amazing
like first of all uh i believe in this
model of education as sort of
the way of the future how many kids
though actually
have or it's probably not just kids i'm
sure it's a lot of adults also trying to
continue their education how many people
have gone through this
yeah so we have about 40 000 people who
have
finished free code camp and gone and
gotten a job as a software engineer
40 000. uh and those people haven't paid
a dime they just sat down and
grinded really hard for like several
years in most cases and and
there are some kids nobody under 13
please don't use our site it's illegal
uh according to kappa so if we find out
you're under 13 we have to delete your
account
but but the average like the median age
of people who use free cooking
closer to 30 um 31. wow so it is a lot a
lot of adults
uh trying to kind of future proof
themselves i mean i think it's no secret
that the world is going to a more tech
code-centered world and even knowing
some code even if you don't want to be a
software developer can be extremely
useful
at your job anywhere you really are uh
is the goal of most people to pivot away
to a new education
is it to give themselves like a better
life i mean what what's kind of what you
hear from the community
yeah absolutely so the people who use
free cocaine generally like
they already are working in some
capacity because
it's it's the community for uh busy
adults essentially most of them are
working full-time
a lot of them have kids mortgages you
know maybe elderly
uh parents and relatives they're taken
care of uh or people with disabilities
you know they're busy they don't have a
lot of time and what we do
is we break everything up into extremely
bite-sized little chunks where you can
hop
on and you know productively code maybe
30 minutes a day i
i can like preach about this all day but
basically
you want to take time you want to take a
few years to learn all this knowledge
it's a lot
uh if you try to like drink from the
proverbial fire hose you're going to
find yourself without a lot of face
so i would definitely recommend just
taking it easy and
planning to stay in school stay at your
job don't do anything dramatic or risky
and just gradually you know expand your
skills and transition
into a more technical role that for some
people that could be becoming a
full-blown software engineer
for some people that could be becoming a
full-blown data scientist
for a lot of people that just means
being more effective in their you know
uh accounting practice or their you know
marketing
consultancy or whatever it is they're
doing like you can use code so many
different ways you can make your life so
much easier
just by automating the tedious parts of
your job and being able to focus on
you know the dynamic stuff that actually
involves thinking
i love this so i don't know how much you
know about coffeezilla but we're
more focused on like a lot of scams
um and often times people go oh well
what can i
rely on is like an uh like a resource or
an
educational thing and i can happily
recommend
things that are uh free but i think as
you said
it's important to like note that any
kind of worthwhile thing
education otherwise job prospect it
takes time
and i appreciate you saying that it
takes like multiple years is that
usually what you guys find like two to
three years to go
through i mean the fastest somebody
who's completed
our curriculum which is about you know
two thousand hours worth of coursework
uh this this very uh ambitious
uh he's already a you know professional
software engineer he went through our
curriculum but basically his review and
still took him 29 days basically speed
running it
all day yeah he speed ran the free
cocaine curriculum in 29 days
so it's it's a lot to take in and you
know i mean it when i say like don't
expect to be a developer in like nine
months
even if you were to go to like one of
these intensive coding bootcamps like
you're gonna spend a whole lot of time
preparing for that and or you're gonna
not really get a lot out of it because
you have to have a strong baseline
knowledge if you're going to try to gear
up and learn intensively
and then what they often don't tell you
is it takes months and months and months
of job search
to get a job like a perfect example if
you
if you google coding bootcamps you'll
find like this article by somebody
freco camp community who wrote about
like he went to berkeley he already had
like
i think like an undergraduate
engineering degree from berkeley
and he went to the most i guess
prestigious coding boot camp at the time
2016-ish
and he still had to apply to hundreds of
jobs in order to get satisfactory job
offers and he ultimately did get like
six job offers and some were really good
but it took him months and months and a
lot of it wasn't just like a
you know applied to five jobs a day it
was like that was his full-time job
so there are tons of opportunities there
are hundreds of thousands of
open positions for software engineers
around the world
but people are very risk-averse when
they hire because
it you know it's one bad software
engineer can do a lot of damage to a
code base and a lot of them should
the more relevant organization quincy i
think something
that like you sort of represent
is the open source paradigm
open internet free internet versus you
know
uh also another very popular model
which is the paid paypal like the
for-profit model can you give me
your explanation as to why you made free
code camp uh
free i mean it is kind of
counterintuitive why not make money from
the thing
uh you can make a lot more of it
yeah yeah so this is probably gonna be a
long answer there's this famous uh
speech uh from stuart brand uh creator
of the whole earth catalog
big inspiration to both uh you know
steve jobs and steve wozniak
uh early days you know palo alto
he said information wants to be free and
everybody hears that everybody's heard
that expression
information wants to be free but what he
said immediately afterward he said and
it also wants to be very expensive
because the right information in the
right place
can totally change your life and i i
feel like
wow that's brilliant i internalize the
information wants to be free and
everybody else internalized the last
half of that which is much more menacing
you know so uh for me like it was never
a question like i put free at the
beginning of
free code camp i'm gonna try not to
spill you know t on my laptop there but
free code camp i put that right at the
beginning because i'm like this is
always gonna be free i want people to
know it's free
i don't want people to think it's like
some bait and switch right because
it's like that value is very important
to me like i grew up
hearing information wants to be free and
feeling that and to some extent
living that um and i you know i just
spent my days in the library like
reading books and
and uh you know living the kind of
bohemian lifestyle of just like crashing
on a mattress on the floor and then
getting up and going back to the library
and uh for me i met tons of people in
california when i moved out to
california
uh santa barbara area just tons of
people that that didn't really
care about money that much i mean
granted it's a relatively
wealthy place so it's easy to not care
about money when you know
you don't have to worry about freezing
to death during the winter and you don't
have to worry about like
uh you know other things that people
have to worry about right
uh it's a very privileged part of the
united states uh but i
i hung out there and i was just really
impressed that like these people could
just like
conjure money from thin air i had a
friend who was just
he had like a six core pc that was doing
nothing but mining
bitcoin all throughout 2012 2013. it's a
good time to mine
yeah that was a very good time to mine
and he didn't care
like like this guy was the most
uh aesthetic person i'd ever met
right like like he had this cheap little
netbook that he posted on because it was
lightweight and he could carry it
and uh he just wore the same clothes
every day and like you go to his room
and all it is is
a desk that he put his laptop on and a
bed and he lived with this uh
this quadriplegic guy who was tragically
injured during a um
during a uh like just a a pool accident
he dove into shallow water and you
in his entire life use water pollution
but he lived with them because
they would give him a hundred bucks a
month and uh just let him live there for
free if he if he kind of helped out
around the house because people who
require please have lots of needs and i
was just incredibly inspired by that guy
like he took the bus he didn't drive
uh you know he didn't really spend any
money at all he ate the exact same
meals he would go to subway and he had
this exact same extremely healthy like
sandwich
that he had prepared with like grilled
chicken and all the vegetables and a
little bit of olive oil and stuff
and that's like for him life was very
simple it was like
the closest you can get to like a life
of mind that you imagine like socrates
or confucius right and that for me
he was such a huge inspiration for me
and that
like at the time i was you know like the
typical
middle class middle manager in a large
you know japanese corporation basically
running like a school
and i've been a teacher and a school
director for the past 10 years and
done that in the us and china and all
the stuff and i've seen
like how i haven't lived in china for
six years just seeing
how little people live with um going out
into the countryside
and and seeing people who like they
would just play mahjong and then they go
back to the rice fields
and that was their life right um that
was their life they had like this kind
of shared
war that they lived in yeah and uh
you know the migrant workers and
everybody and and for me it was just
like wow if they can make do with all
that and like here i am like
you know with like a suit and like my
own nice air-conditioned office and all
this stuff and
i'm not gonna say it was like a like a
you know go to india
type moment and like walk around
barefoot like steve jobs
experience or anything like that but or
jack dorsey is trying to live out every
day
yeah yeah the difference is steve jobs
wasn't like a billionaire who was
you know with a nose ring when he did it
i'm sorry i don't want to rip too much
on jack dorsey at least he banned
that one guy but um yeah
for me free is is a state of mind like
if
i feel like if you if you're blessed
with abundance to the extent that
you know most middle class americans are
whether they want to acknowledge it or
not
to some extent like you have a duty
should you choose to hear
keep the call to go out and try to help
other people and
the fact that i think is probably the
most important single fact
that defines my life is the knowledge
that
about sixty percent of people on earth
live off like five dollars and fifty
cents a day
just imagine that for a second and there
might be somebody who are watching some
people who are watching this
who are in that demographic because
youtube fortunately is free
and you can if you have a smartphone
which most people do you can watch
things on youtube it's staggering to
think about like
a lot of people spend more than that on
their phone bill each month right and
yet people are living off of that
and people don't necessarily have credit
cards they're unbanked
if you put even like a dollar you know
pay wall on your website
it it shuts people out absolutely so
yeah for me it was very important that
if we wanted to have like
true accessibility in the socioeconomic
sense of the word
then we needed to make sure that
everything was free
and nothing was pay walled and to this
day like i refused to put
any sort of premium you know behind the
paywall content on freecodecamp like
we actually had a big falling out with
uh medium
because they wanted us to put stuff
behind a paywall and we were refused
and we it was very costly but we were
able to move all of our publication off
of medium
as a result of that and and uh yeah
it's important free is uh for me it's
it's
the most powerful word free and and we
all want to be free
and we want to be free from want and and
part of that is
um being able to get what we need and
what we need
so much of in this life is just basic
knowledge to be able to
earn what we need to be able to provide
for our families and to be able to
sustain ourselves and our communities
and you know
once once prosperity's totally gone once
you have like a true failed state like
somalia
things get very bad very quickly and i
don't want to see any
society fall into that and we don't it
doesn't have to information
is infinitely reproducible there's no
reason that we have to charge
money for information you know mit put
their entire curriculum out in like the
turn of the century right
like the entire mit curriculum opened
courseware you could just go and learn
from the best engineering school perhaps
in human history
that is really mind-blowing but one of
the things the nature of online
education has really transformed also
even the value proposition from needing
to be i mean at
at one point you needed to pay teachers
to constantly be
showing up again and again and again
nowadays the cost of producing education
has
lowered actually and so the fact that we
see
increasing college costs i guess i don't
rant against this enough
that's a crime the fact that we see
increasing
um all these like paid courses and stuff
it's like no actually education's va
like
value it's not that it's value-less
but the ability to produce it at scale
has ma has exploded with the internet
with the rise of online video now you
don't have to have
the same teacher show up every year you
can record their
best performance you can get the best
teacher on earth to show up teach one
time
and then show it to millions of people
so
that is even a better case for what
you're saying
um when you look at the coding
experience i mean what was your
background going through it because
surely
it wasn't free code camp did not exist
when you got started
what what's your educational background
and yeah um
were you the kind of first to market on
this as far as the free code camp stuff
yeah so um i'll just give you a very
high level
overview so i i did go to i dropped out
of high school as a sophomore
like lived in my car for a year or two
and just worked at taco bell
and at some point i was like man i i do
not want to be doing this for the rest
of my life and i'm grateful that that
happened
you know pre-covered because i would
have been screwed like working it like
talk
i almost certainly would have caught it
and uh been you know one of the
millions of americans who lost their job
or
had other hardships as a result so it's
on the timing right like
definitely survivorship bias was in my
favor
um but uh yeah so i did that and
eventually i went back to like
state schools uh the very same state
cool schools
that you know our president joe biden
went to um
that he's pushing for essentially free
community college that's the kind of
education i got
and it was very powerful because uh i
got to
learn what i needed to learn and this is
gonna probably
you know spur some ire some envy but i
only paid like a thousand dollars
a semester to attend it was very
inexpensive in oklahoma city where i
grew up
uh and then i had the opportunity to go
abroad
and i did a graduate program in tianjin
which is right outside of beijing
and i did like an intensive chinese
program i was the only
uh the only white guy the only uh with
the
guy who was your grad on campus
what was your graduate what'd you study
in graduate school i did an mba
oh sorry nba okay got it got it yeah so
so i i do understand like
basic economics and and it's interesting
what you said about education
and prices going up like if you look at
like economic textbooks like like
hayek not just the textbooks but the
actual economists like milton
uh friedman uh you know for your kayak
um you know uh keynes you look at those
people
and like they kind of almost just
assumed that technology was gonna
continue to drive prices down
it's weird that prices are going up for
anything really
because technology is supposed to make
things cheaper that's what it does it
makes widgets
it makes the manufacturing of which is
more effective it makes the delivery of
service more
effective and it has made it more
effective it had like it
has made it easier to produce
but there are obviously what
the saying that you said earlier has
held true that information wants to be
free it also wants to be really
expensive because people come around in
my experience and say
hey you're going to get like our paywall
will give you access to some
magical secret and there is something
very enticing about that where people
humans kind of naturally assume well if
it's expensive
it must be quality right if it's
expensive
it must have some secret that justifies
its magical pricing
what you actually find out is there
isn't such an easy correlation as you
might assume because as you said like
literally mit's course where it's online
for free
yeah there's there's you know like
demand curves if you look at demand
curves
traditionally you know supply and demand
price goes down right yeah uh where the
two meet right
and uh what you can have is you can have
upward sloping demand
where like a luxury good for example
because it's
it's luxury it's got this halo and the
more expensive it gets the more people
want it like there's that iphone app
that's like
like i'm rich iphone app or whatever and
you paid a thousand dollars you got this
thing and it's just like this diamond
that says you're rich
and that was the app and people like
tons of people paid for that
you know it's wasteful that we have
people that are so rich because
they don't really appreciate it the
marginal utility of having
more than like eighty thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars depending on
how many kids you have
in income a year it just rapidly drops
off and
you know if you meet a lot of you know
multi-millionaires often they'll be you
know miserable sons of [ __ ]
they're not really that happy and yet if
you took even a force from their wealth
and transferred it to like
the single mothers and all the other
people that that are are
basically uh in dire straits you could
dramatically transform their lives
but we don't do that because we you know
the people
get addicted to having this this number
you know like nolan bushnell
the creator of atari and chuck cheese um
has this great quote he says business is
a game
you keep score with money and that's
that's how it works like in their mind
they just want to drive that number as
high as possible it's irrational
why whenever i meet somebody who's like
a multi-millionaire
i always ask them like so so why do you
want to be rich and they they look at me
incredulously but if they actually think
about it and try to give me an answer
it's usually just to minimize downside
risk to get like health insurance
and like oh if i have cancer i'll be
able to afford good treatments stuff
like that yeah
everybody in sweden gets that just for
existing
you know they just pay like a slightly
higher marginal tax rate and they have
health care they have good education
that doesn't cost an arm and a leg
you know coming out of business school i
was very much into thinking like oh you
know like america's got a lot of things
figured out
um you know there's you know capitalism
is really effective it's
the market mechanism is really powerful
and the more i kind of like grew older
and like read more and more about
economics the more i came to realize
like
you know there are certain sectors where
the market mechanisms can corrupt things
more than they can help and
education and healthcare are two of
those sectors you know i'm i'm
definitely like a defender of capitalism
and i think that like a lot of the
innovation
that's come out has been because we've
had you know
globalization and uh capitalism and like
you know different organizations
competing for consumer dollars and
competing for you know government
funding things like that right but um
it really falls apart when you look at
the american healthcare system when you
look at the american education system
like uh i know so many people
who've gone to serve overseas in the
military who come back and they've got
this gi bill
and they got suckered into some horrible
for-profit university
boom this is javier's gone they've got a
worthless degree
and some you know betsy devos has got an
extra yacht
the the for-profit school system is
yeah it's really bad and and it is
interesting how
uh forces that can be very good can also
kind of work completely in the opposite
direction
um let's talk about i mean how this
intersects with what you do every day
because obviously you live
breathe kind of like this code camp and
obviously there are a lot of different
people popping up
obviously tech is the hot thing it's
been the hot thing for a long time it
looks to be the hot thing for
a very long time in the future
how do you see yourself within
um the market obviously there are people
i talked about
um well i've let's just say i've talked
about
a coding camp in the past who was you
know charging a lot of money telling
parents
they need they pay this premium their
kid will get you know
a a super job somewhere at google or
whatever
how does that work here can you make a
case
for why that uh is valuable is not
valuable etc
yeah yeah well um a lot of it's just a
big sales job
you know uh one thing to do is go on
google adwords
create like a google adwords account um
and just look at how much it costs to
bid for
you know university degree like certain
keywords like
bachelor's degree in nursing or a
graduate degree
or coding bootcamp that's another one
that like if you search
uh for for coding bootcamp you're gonna
get like
potentially three or four ads on top of
your google results because
uh if you have to advertise a whole lot
for something that does say something
in my opinion you know uh people have to
advertise like tide
for going and washing their clothes
right because it's boring and people are
like
you know but if something's truly
compelling
there's a question about how much you
really need to advertise for it
um and a lot of as you you know trader
joe's
i've learned more from trader joe's and
i've learned from looking a lot of tech
companies uh about like just
hi that's really interesting why why is
that i mean they just care about quality
and they they don't waste money
or waste money and they don't plow money
into the diminishing returns things like
advertising
advertising is diminishing returns like
like at some point it it ceases to make
sense
to plow more money into advertising
because you're your you know
lifetime value of uh quincy you've
offended so many people in this
interview
already i thought you were before but
now you really are
advertising is diminishing returns
explain yeah well
uh at some point it does make sense it's
rational to keep
running google ads or facebook ads too
to raise awareness of something
but uh at some point you've kind of
saturated the market or
it's so competitive that your cost of
acquiring a customer if i can remember
the acronyms
correct your cac which is like a cool
archaic word for [ __ ]
um so your cac is uh so high that it's
the the um the expected value
of getting somebody on your uh
on your product is not worth it so uh
but
it's surprisingly high like i remember a
while back i was looking at like
you know university of phoenix and uh
other kind of online universities we're
spending like 400
per click from google results think
about that think about that
so a university is before you've even
joined
they assume that a certain number of
people who click through are not going
to actually enroll
so maybe twelve hundred sixteen hundred
dollars
they've spent just to get you kind of
like enrolled in their program
before they've actually even started
spending money on teachers right and
something to
to know that all appears at the balance
sheet of you paying for it you've got to
pay for your own
customer acquisition cost i mean that's
always rolled into the price
yeah somebody's got to pay there are no
free lunches yeah no i mean
but that means that the university of
arizona a lot of the tuition fee
maybe even university percentage
uh yeah sorry what did i say you said
university of arizona
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry there's nothing
wrong with the university of arizona i'm
just sorry specifically calling out
university of phoenix
excuse me excuse me the university of
phoenix uh a lot of your tuition is
going straight to google
or facebook or whatever adwords campaign
they're running
so so in the startup ecosystem it used
to be back in the dot-com bubble
that like yahoo was like this giant 100
billion dollar
company and the reason was every single
company that got funded
would go and buy a big banner ad at the
top of yahoo.com
and that was a huge poor like their seed
round maybe their series a was just
going to yahoo
and now your seed round your series a is
going to two things
one it's going to developers to build
your product because the developers get
paid one way or another right
they're like they're the ultimate like
pickaxes
in the gold rush um and the other is
advertising on google and facebook like
that's 70
of online advertising right there just
those two companies so
google and facebook get really rich off
of the venture capital
kind of ecosystem which is constantly uh
churning out startups that are going to
spend a whole bunch of money advertising
to try to get initial traction and
find product market fit how much
advertising have you done with free code
campaign
zero zero never not at google gave us 10
000
a month in free advertising and we just
didn't even bother using it we used it
for like a month or two but like it just
stopped working because they asked for
something else
yeah whatever how many people are on
your site daily
you said absolutely that is mind-blowing
that's such a great case study for like
for you know
building something that has a really
strong value proposition you've done
zero advertising and you have a
recurring base of
half a million students basically
what are students how literally
you just said it though right there is
no such thing as a free lunch
so how do you um
obviously you're a non-profit but how do
you like make money
through donations i mean as soon as you
get paid something yeah everything is
donations
so uh people when you know who graduate
from free coconut often they'll turn
around and like hey i just
you know increase my earning potential
by twenty thirty thousand dollars a year
i mean sometimes it can be more extreme
it's a lot better of an offer than the
university thing
i've got to say i was offended when i
realized that my university
texas a m was going to spend the next
i don't know however long i live and
probably well after i die
amount of time now calling me and asking
for more money after
you've already made you know tens of
thousands of dollars
yeah so at least with you guys you guys
it's on the back it's on the back and
yeah i mean if
and what we're interested we're not
interested in large single you know
one-time donations you can definitely do
that we're actually doing a pleasure
drive right now to create a data science
curriculum
uh wait i don't want to talk too much
about that because i don't want to bore
you with the details but if you want to
help out we're building like a really
elaborate like math and computer science
and data science machine learning
curriculum
but uh that that's kind of like a pledge
drive that's ongoing but
uh in general we just like to have a
broad coalition of grassroots support
we'd much rather have like
right now we have about seven thousand
people who give us five dollars a month
and i'd much rather have seven thousand
people who give us five dollars a month
than one person that gives us 35 000 a
month or um you know
ten people that give us three thousand
five hundred dollars you know it just
gets really brittle when you're relying
on these rich people
to support everything so it's
and there's always a chance to have a
stable budget yeah there's also we can
make payroll and pay for servers
yeah excuse me sorry it's also a much
better chance that you get some weird
conflicts of interest
when you have one guy sustaining you or
10 guys because all of a sudden you're
really beholden to those people
whereas if you're beholden to a large
like consumer base who actually uses the
product that's a totally different
um set of interests that you have to
maintain
because you're literally your mandate is
to make the product
better as it should be what is the i
mean
i saw this with khan academy i saw this
video by uh sal
khan i think is his name i'm a huge fan
of his
and it's because of the amount of people
he's serving
per the dollar that's actually spent on
him i mean there's
obviously this big push for what i don't
forget what it's called like altruistic
giving
basically it's the idea that giving
affected us yeah
it has utility and like there's good
ways to give there's kind of
all giving is good but there's also dumb
ways to give like less effective ways to
give
um do you know like how many dollars are
spent a year
per student served i think that's like a
really interesting
fact to think about so i calculate this
and i publish it every year
because we're re like i mean we're a
50163 donor supporting nonprofit same
tax
status as khan academy same tech status
is like you know the red cross and
doctors without borders
um so we have to publicly disclose all
this stuff including my income
if you're curious how much does it make
you can go check um so
uh what we do is we put everything into
what's called a 990 and we do it but i
also put out like an annual report every
year
and one of the things i do is i crunch
the numbers of like how many uh
minutes people use for eco camp uh and
then
how much money we spent what was our
budget for the year right and last year
i think it was close to 50
hours worth of learning for every dollar
donated to free go game
because we had two points uh we had one
point
1.2 1.3 billion minutes of usage
which translates to 2500 years
so it's like going way back before jesus
if we were to like go back in time
that's the amount of time
that people use free code camp last year
um and
and and the cool thing about that is
that means that there are about 2
500 people using free code camp right
now as you and i talk
that's amazing that's it's such an
effective
use of money and one thing that um
i struggle with is that a lot of the
people who
i talk about on my show the only reason
they're educating
i mean like yeah
the incentives do kind of get perverse
when you're like trying to become a
millionaire by
teaching people like get rich online but
like
this is so kind of refreshing talking to
you because your whole point is
how effectively can we literally teach
kids per dollar
and that's uh that's kind of amazing 50
hours per
dollar i hope you guys are paying
attention if you're
an a user of click funnels or something
like that
but that's that's completely insane
i think it's interesting your job is to
teach more people with less money and a
for-profit education is to make
more money per hour spent that's an
interesting way to
to think about it um and it's not just
for-profit education like like there are
ton there's tons of room for uh
improvement in systems
and this isn't i don't blame individual
people usually for the state of like say
the u.s education system but to give you
some
some quick concrete numbers i think most
people on this call
have most people watching this uh have
uh
probably gone to school at some point
and and like if you went to school in
america
in the united states every year that you
went to school it cost about ten
thousand dollars now in new york city
it's a lot more than that but like on
average that's the median that america
spends
per student purchase and we're not
talking about college we're talking
about we're talking about like k through
12 yeah like like sixth grade
so let's say you have a sixth grade
teacher and she has a class of
you know 40 people yep that means
that her class is essentially 400
000 a year is allocated to teaching
those people in her class
does she get paid 400 000 a year no no
no no no i know a lot of great teachers
who deserve
uh deserve a lot more money but they get
paid yeah pittance
there's in you know you could argue they
should be paid certainly a lot more than
they are
but why why is it why are we spending so
much money
on education and there's just like this
waste exhaust
i feel like a lot of people would say
that the quality of education
is also lacking so not only is the cost
of education extremely high
but the quality of education is also
um you might say really questionable
yeah
can technology change that i don't think
technology alone
can like completely transform it for
everybody and we're seeing the limits of
technology
at least with the imagination that our
current like educators
and administrators i mean just to be
clear like
i don't think that the teachers are
responsible for a lot of the the
deficiencies in american like
performance on like for example the
standardized tests like
like we get our asses kicked if you
compare us
like singapore or or shanghai which was
like
for some reason its own they didn't test
everybody in china oh yes
but like all these different countries
like like we're pretty low
for all the oecd countries right right
and yet we spend probably more than most
countries do
most wealthy countries on education the
education problem is i didn't mean to
simplify it my mom's a teacher
and her hands are often tied by the
administration um
so yeah i want to make that really clear
yeah so just to be 100 clear like i'm
just saying systems
these are problems with systems
administration like why do we have
schools why are classes the same like
the link that they are
what do we have 12 grades and the only
way to advance to the next grade is turn
a year older
like there's so there's so much
irrationality like like
we really need to look at the we need to
return to first principles
and figure out why is education the way
it is you know sao khan actually whom
you mentioned earlier has a book called
one world schoolhouse
uh where he talks about a lot of these
kind of notions
um but for me i think that
a lot of it is just like it's expensive
to run a school and to
air condition it and you know every
school has to have a gym every school
has to have a football team
and like like pretty soon you've got all
these non-academic related costs that
just
stack up and then how much is there
actually left
at the end of the year like the teachers
are buying
school supplies you know and can get a
teacher discount so that they can take
the school supplies provide them for
their class
because the school doesn't provide it
when there's four hundred thousand
dollars per class per year
you know it's insane and and that's like
i don't think the school systems pay
taxes or anything either so that's like
it's like after tax you know it's it's
ridiculous
um so yeah i i don't want to sound like
i'm just knocking
like american uh k-12 education
universities
sort of truism at this point among most
uh
people who've been through the
educational system in the past 50 years
uh everyone sort of experienced a very
sort of similar experience i i don't
think many people would consider it
knocking it as much as you're just sort
of stating the fact of the
the situation what i'm trying to say
though to answer your original question
sorry for this
response uh is technology is not some
panacea that's just gonna make all our
troubles go away oh technology just
just increase the technology budget and
no because those
those administrators are gonna go out
and get really crappy erp
systems um and like yeah different
database tools from like oracle or some
you know corporation that like
builds people books governments books
institutions
uh big enterprise sales person is going
to take the cio to golf
and they're gonna and the money's not
gonna be well spent
so the answer is not to empower
organizations at the top to make big
sweeping technological choices because
uh that
we've seen where that goes um and you
can walk on walk into any university
system and look at like their
you know go in go back there look at
what the university admins what tools
are they working with
i know at like university of california
santa barbara i had a friend who was a
prof there and he said that in the admin
like they like every computer on the
campus had netscape navigator 5
installed
because there were systems that could
only run
using netscape navigator 5. they
couldn't run anymore contemporary
browsers and they were mission critical
and i mean this is like one of the
wealthiest public university systems
in the world so the answer is to have
the teachers themselves make a lot of
the technology decisions
and have kind of like this bottom-up
percolation it's kind of like a dropbox
model as opposed to box if you're
familiar with the corporate you know
equivalent of dropbox
costs ten times as much right yeah yeah
so you know it's
it's basically like if everybody's like
hey i'm using dropbox and you're using
dropbox let's just get a team account
right
like problem solved for a fraction of
what it would cost if you've got an
oracle involved
yeah so i think i think empowering the
individual people with technology
is what we need what we don't need is
big broad sweeping like
high level initiatives i think that's
really important and it
goes back to what seems like your
fundamental philosophy
on funding as well which is also more
grassroots
focused quincy i um
talking to you i'm sort of struck
because given
obviously your website's you know
extreme popularity
um you're sort of i don't know if you
look at yourself like this because
you're you're sort of understated uh
we've talked before
but you're one of the front like you're
one of the leaders of this
like open education movement because
you're a
model of how this can you know work
how do you see it going in the next 10
years for free code cap
how do you see it going for the guy
who's going to create the next free code
camp
yeah well i think open source is
powerful you know there's there's that
whole
um that whole quote about like bill
gates
said that uh he and steve jobs like both
had this wealthy neighbor
uh over at xerox park and uh
bill gates broke in to steal his tv only
to discover that steve jobs had already
broken in and stolen it first
with the uh macintosh um you know i feel
like to some extent like
i'm just some random teacher who uh
learned a little bit of programming
skills and like wandered into this you
know
emporium of open source software and i
was like the only customer in the entire
thing and there were just people like
hey
try our software try our software it was
amazing and uh you know free code camp
like
uh i basically just used tons of trapped
together a bunch of
open source libraries together and and
got got things going
and free code camp itself of course is
open source and we use the very
permissive bsd3 license and a lot of
people use mit license
there are less permissive open source uh
licenses so they're not all the same
you don't need a law degree to like
parse the two but but
generally if it's mit or if it's bsd uh
you're probably good
by the way uh but but yeah we i saw that
i saw creative commons like
books creative commons licensed courses
all all these
tools that we could use and we managed
to
strap together tons of different
tools into like a full-fledged learning
curriculum and uh you know a community
like our
forum software right that's open source
uh the internet radio
station code radio that's running on my
friend
uh his his tool called azuracast that's
basically just like a
free open source internet radio station
you pay like 15 bucks a month and you
can like host your own internet radio
right um same thing with chat there's
this this company
out of brazil called rocket chat it's
basically like self-hosted slack that's
open source
we paid nothing except for the server
and we've got like our own
enterprise level self-hosted slack
that doesn't leak any data out to like
salesforce or any of these other
companies right it's just like ours
you can own the future and most of it is
free you just go grab it and
code is infinitely reproducible so you
just uh you spin up your own server
and it it just blows my mind that like
more people are turning to these big
enterprise
companies for solutions when so many
solutions are open source and you can
just like with a
a little bit a little bit of technology
acumen and a lot of curiosity
you can very quickly build your own
system and i am confident that
there's not going to be like a next free
code camper say it's going to be
thousands of little free code camps it's
gonna be the equivalent of like like
cleveland is gonna have its own like
some enterprising teachers are gonna put
together
this uh this system that like all the
teachers band together
and at some point it's gonna it's not
gonna make sense to have individual
schools
or individual like i see the future of
education as just a bunch of strip malls
somebody rents a a room like a shop
on that strip mall and sets up some
desks and maybe get some some old
you know linux based lab computers and
stuff and people just go there and they
learn
and it's like a community school where
people teach one another this may sound
like
you know utopian and stuff but this
happens like there are people doing this
right now
in india there are people doing this
right now in nigeria and places where
like they don't have the the wealth that
we have to to keep this behemoth
continuing to run the way the the
current education
industry works in the us so we're going
to see all kinds of innovation
and um i hope that free cocaine can be a
part of it you know there are
programs that take pre-co camp and put
it on
computer labs inside prisons so that
people can learn valuable job skills
while they're in prison when they can't
access the internet you know you can run
free cocaine completely entirely
on your local area network so
there's tremendous potential to take
education and essentially federate it
um and uh not have these big you know
not not be beholden to these gatekeepers
like the us federal government for
example
or like um you know specific uh
school districts and things like that
and in the u.s
homeschool laws are extremely permissive
and
you could easily just create your own
school so i i hope more people will do
that
you've convinced me now i want to add
one context before we wrap up here
because uh you're a very charismatic
dude with a vision for education that a
lot of people are going to find
really resonant one interesting thing on
my show is we have a series called real
jobs we just talk to people about how
they sort of found themselves
in these places that they do because i'm
a big believer that
sort of you kind of you kind of find
your
your way and you kind of find jobs you
may never have expected to find yourself
in and that's okay it's actually a
normal part of the human experience
you probably never saw yourself as like
the founder of this
you know company uh educating so many
kids
connect the dots between so you're in
japan sort of this
administrator i feel like we got a
picture of sort of who you were you're
looking up to this bohemian guy who
realized you know maybe materialism
isn't
totally uh the great answer you know
once you survive
past your your survival needs it becomes
largely irrelevant
so you're looking for sort of like this
like maybe this like larger purpose or
something how did you go from that
middle manager and connect the dots all
the way to free code camp
sure well first of course i spent years
learning the code
and working as a software engineer and
doing freelance jobs and stuff
which was interesting because i was 31
when i learned to code and a lot of
people like assume
oh i'm not some you know 23 year old
stanford grad i can't learn to code
uh and i'm actually like this is such a
i guess endemic
misconception that i had to create i
created an entire hashtag right there's
like a giant twitter list if you
search dev after 30. um and i wrote like
a big article where i like show some of
the experiences of these people
but a lot of people think like oh i'm
set like my brain is like
you know in this mold and it's jello and
it's not gonna move around it's already
dried right like
that is the most uh i guess limiting way
that you can look at
your personal development the reality is
like i
during the pandemic i started playing
bass right and like i started like
learning like slap bass and like uh
memorizing the fretboard and
and just playing tons of awesome like
police songs from the 70s and the clash
and stuff like that right
so uh i'm 40 years old right like
i'm sure plenty of people would see like
oh well you you know you always hear
like the first thing you hear when you
read about a musician he started playing
piano when he's four
right it's it's a joke like i think
adults can learn way better than kids i
have two young kids
i try to teach them all the time listen
i'm a big believer in this
i think adults are limited by time but
actually your ability to
even understand the meta skill of
learning increases with age and so yeah
and there is
like there is some truth to that where
you can if if an
adult is serious enough and they're
willing to take on that beginner's
mindset they can learn a lot i i taught
myself piano and
i really never got started i took
lessons as a kid i hated it
eventually i sort of got started when i
was like i don't know
12 13 but even i got much better
when i actually became an adult and i
actually was sort of like enjoying
playing et cetera
but i had the exact experience i was
like yeah this i don't know i
i agree i agree 100 agree i think it's
interesting that you're a case study for
your own product though that you're not
i
assume talking to you that you were some
stanford grad or whatever i mean you
said you're a state school
but i assumed sort of oh you had to have
had a background
so interesting to me that you are
exactly in that demographic
that your own product teaches
yeah i mean i was know this about you i
was 31 years old
and that's when i created freako camp
and and got people involved and
and i was able to like you know the best
the best mascot i guess the best
spokesman is somebody who
is not just a member but product of the
client
yeah it's true though yeah yeah like
like i'm i'm basically applying my
hard-won wisdom
about what does work and what doesn't
work and i went down tons of blind alex
man
like i spent i spent years like banging
my head like
thinking i was an imposter if you look
if you google like
business insider quincy larson you know
imposter syndrome something like that
right like you'll find this
business center like profiled me and my
experiences with
imposter syndrome working at uh you know
a tech startup
as a 30 year old you know guy who's on
his first developer job
i mean like i've lived that experience
and i can kind of relate to people
so i can tell you if you are watching
this and you want to learn to code
any sufficiently motivated person can
learn to code
you don't it has very little to do with
iq or aptitude
i mean if you believe in evolution and
you believe that like humans originated
in africa
and that we were basically just running
around like killing animals and like
burning them and eating them and stuff
and that was like our heritage
you're gonna think like okay were there
computers back then was there like
abstract mathematics was like any of
this stuff that software engineers use
was it selected for over a hundred
thousand years of evolution
no you know like like the only
difference that i can see
is the kids who the rich kids who got a
computer when they were young like the
the mark zuckerbergs who by the way his
parents like paid for him to
have programming tutoring for like years
and years before he got into harvard
as a cs student by the way so like a lot
of it is just like
you know social economic privilege like
many things right um so
just because they act like programming
is easy and everything
you know the things that you learn when
you're a kid you tend to forget how hard
they were when you learn them
absolutely so don't ever believe
somebody when they say programming's
easy or a program just came naturally to
me
you know when somebody says like that
something like that i just immediately
kind of say like well you've forgotten
the beginner's mindset what we call an
education
the learner's mindset uh you have
forgotten what it's like to be
at the beginning and to see this giant
see that you have to somehow swallow up
and but you know it's the same way you
do anything it's just like one step at a
time
one day after a day you know if you if
you were to sit down and code 30 minutes
a day
every day for the next two or three
years you would be a better
potentially better programmer than a lot
of the people who are out in the field
you'd probably almost certainly be
better off than people that like got a
cs degree or
um you know um
went to an intensive program a coding
bootcamp because
you would have tons of practice and not
just practice but
like practice day after day uh
and just that day like working on
something for a little bit then going to
sleep
having all that etch into your brain and
then waking up and starting where you
were
that process that is everything like
forming the habits
uh forming that muscle memory and one
other thing i'll say
uh that i think is very important it's a
lonely process
and you can definitely get daunted you
can definitely feel
insufficient uh everybody does
everybody feels impostor syndrome i
think but
having a community hanging out with
people that are also developers that was
like my lifeline like i
i knew that guy i knew the the the uh
the guy who
just mined bitcoin and like coded all
day and like he was kind of my mentor
and then i hung out with him and i hung
out with a whole bunch of other place
people at like this place called the
santa barbara hackerspace
and that was kind of like my community
that was my tribe that i got pulled into
they they took me in they took some some
weird you know 30 year old dude in a
suit they took him into their
their you know uh software development
club
and treated me as one of their own in in
that inclusiveness like that was
definitely something that i wanted to
build
into free code camp as well it's just a
sense of making people feel belong
that's incredible i don't know how much
i can
i can add to that it's that's i you know
what's funny is uh i rarely get
spellbound by
the people i'm interviewing story but i
was like kind of like listening as if i
was like an audience member there for a
second
um that's amazing i hope other people
can find their tribe
whether it be coding or anything in a
space
that prioritizes their learning in the
same spirit
uh that you do thanks quincy thanks for
coming on thanks for coming on the show
discussing all these things if you want
to find them you can find them on
twitter
at quincy larson where else can people
find you obviously they can go learn to
code at free code camp yeah yeah just go
to freecodecamp.org
and uh take a look um and when you sign
up you're gonna get like this little
spiel from me
that tells you like coding's hard like
basically like trying to sell you and
not using
code camp and if you're still like yeah
i should still use free cooking
screw quincy i'm gonna do this you know
then then that means it's meant to be
so uh psychology good reverse psychology
yeah give it a go
and even if you don't end up using it
it's still a valuable skill it's still
fun
and another thing just because you think
you suck at math it just means that you
didn't
like it taught properly like you can
definitely learn math
uh and there's not that much math in a
lot of development so
don't feel like your lack of math skills
is a prerequisite a lot more
just critical thinking and reasoning and
stuff is is kind of the operating thing
you can use as a developer
awesome thanks quincy thanks guys we'll
see you
tomorrow
wake up and smell the coffee